faithful supporters Gather in Saint
Peter's Square in the Vatican to see
Pope Francis one last time before he
undergoes surgery on his abdomen
there's little sign that the Pope's
about to enter hospital as he's in good
spirits greeting members of the crowd
and blessing children soon after the
pontiff made his way in a motor Convoy
to catholic-run jamelli hospital in Rome
obviously we pray for him and hope for
his quick recovery
we always pray for him and at this
particular time he needs our prayers
even more best wishes Holy Father
Pope Francis will undergo plastic
surgery on an abdominal wall to treat a
hernia the Vatican says it's been
causing recurrent and painful symptoms
the pontiff had abdominal surgery in
2021 when he spent 10 days in hospital
after part of his colon was removed
it's a complication of surgery probably
from two years ago I think that a
swelling a hernia like that is not the
most complicated type of procedure
provided that there's not a lot of
intestinal contents inside the hernia I
would expect that it's something that
can be managed and and dealt with fairly
efficiently you know given the the
health care that he will obviously
receive the Vatican says the pontiff
will spend the next few days in Gemelli
Hospital while he recovers from his
surgery
Laura Khan Al Jazeera